Speaker 1: One of the things that some Republicans
have realized they've come to understand this
is that they have sort of lost control of the
monster they created and thought would be a great
thing for them. And that monster is the Trumpists
in the Republican Party. Kevin McCarthy caught on
audio. We now know we talked about it earlier in
the show back in January of 2021, saying We Trump
should resign. Trump should resign. He realized
that they lost control. They were going to ride
the monster. Oh, look at the they're going to
vote. They're voting for Trump, I guess. I guess
we're going to have a Republican president. Let's
go with it. They're willing to vote for Trump.
And then they became a monster they lost control
of and they rioted on January 6th, and the rest
is sort of history. We've also seen them lose
control of the monster when it comes to vaccines.
And Donald Trump recently gave a speech on
Amelia in in on Amelia Island in Florida,
and he wanted to praise the vaccine and take
credit for it. But he knows that his base
might crush him, and he acknowledges sometimes
people get angry when I talk about the vaccine.
Speaker 4: My greatest achievements was getting
the vaccine done in nine months instead of five
and a half to 12 years. But the problem is,
you know, we saved tens of millions of lives
all over the world. But I can't talk about it
because our base, our beautiful base of which
some of you are there, you get angry when
we mention the word vaccine, don't get true.
We did it in nine months, less than nine
months, right? Less than nine months.
Speaker 1: Trump wants his base to be skeptical
of science when it's politically inconvenient,
whatever it might be. Masks, public safety
guidelines, whatever. Don't take unproven
stuff for COVID. But when it's to his benefit, he
wants them to believe in that very science that he
has primed them not to believe, believe in science
when it makes me look good. And this is not a new
thing. Trump knows he's ruined his own base back
in August of 2021. Trump actually got booed when
he talked about the vaccine and how great it is.
Speaker 4: Three days, less than nine months. And
it's great. And you know what? I believe totally
in your freedoms. I do. You got to do what you
have to do, but I recommend taking the vaccines.
I did it. It's good. Take the vaccines. But
you got down. That's OK. Oh, all right. You got
your freedoms. But I happen to take the vaccine.
If it doesn't work, you'll
be the first to know, OK,
I'll call up Alabama and say, Hey, you know what?
Speaker 1: But it's so regularly getting booed,
then heated. This weird thing with Bill O'Reilly,
where there were often unsold
seats and they both said they
got the vaccine and people didn't like it.
Speaker 4: Both the president and I are
vaccinated. You get the booster. Yes, I got
it too. OK, so on da da da da da da nine,
that's always a very tiny group of
Speaker 1: Trump wanting to minimize the booing,
but it was certainly there. And then lastly,
from this very strange speech, just what? This
is just funny because of what it points to for
the next few years. Here's how Trump says we're
going to unite the country. The one that
Speaker 4: we have the path back to
America and unity is not to surrender the
culture wars. The path back to national
unity is to decisively win the culture wars.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, the idea that you're
going to unite the country by winning imaginary
culture wars that you created in order to divide
the country is absurd. It is absurd, but I don't
think Republicans have any other idea. So if I had
to guess in 22 and in 24, their platform will
be. Now we're not going to fix climate, we're
not going to fix health care. We're not going to
fix immigration. We're not going to fix taxes,
but are going to fix anything. We're just going
to win imaginary culture wars that we created
and then say, Hey, we put out a fire. We started
sort of, except it's still on fire and you should
vote for us. Thanks to that. They're telling us
what the strategy will be and I believe them.